bon maintenant je raccroche julie pas
bon pourquoi pas parce que je passe un
tunnel t'as pas envie de parler confié
tantôt plus oui c'est moi un peu bonne
journée
merci merci celui ci lui aurait d'abord
heureuse qu'elle a déjà dit il adore de
faire des surprises
julie j'ai toujours su que tu étais trop
bien pour moi j'en suis désormais
certain je ne suis pas à la hauteur de
tes sentiments
j'aurais aimé te dire tout cela en face
mais j'ai un déjeuner et te respecte
trop pour te quitter par texto je
t'imagine en train de lire cette lettre
ça me déchire le coeur je ne mérite pas
ton pardon tu seras le plus beau
souvenir de ma vie tu l'est déjà